elle est déjà de vouloir faire parler
tous les banlieusards devant lui ces
clichés bruttin en plus pour une fois
j'ai j'ai essayé de faire une la série
mon espace juste en espace en banlieue
c'est le décor mais c'est pas le sujet
voilà dit que les gens y font un truc en
avant lui le sujet c'est la banlieue bon
c'est pas le sujet j'ai écrit sur la
banlieue parce que je connais que ça il
ya un cliché de voir que des cités en
banlieue alors c'est pas le cas il ya
énormément de zones pavillonnaires jeu
quelqu'un qui a grandi en pavillons mais
je suis clairement de la classe moyenne
et par mon parcours de vie notamment par
le football par le collège et aussi
parce que je me suis retrouvé dans
l'équipe d'improvisation des juniors de
trappes
je me suis retrouvé à passer une bonne
partie de ma jeunesse en bas le bâtiment
le site et avec des mecs de cités
j'aime autant le pote qui viennent de
pavillons que deux potes qui viennent de
cité
et c'est vrai que bah ouais c'est
important pour moi parce que je sais pas
si je suis quelqu'un de riche mais très
clairement ce parcours il participe de
ma richesse et participe de ma capacité
à me distinguer de plein d'autres gens
on présente toujours la banlieue comme
s'il y avait absolument aucun mélange
alors que c'est pas vrai c'est pas
étanche s'est pas complètement étanche
parce qu'on est ensemble au collège
parce qu'on a inventé l'école
républicaine
donc c'était plus le cas le banc parce
que maintenant sarkozy l'a tué la carte
scolaire mais à la base ça mais cette
utilité là aussi de créer du mix sociale
il ya un autre cliché qui est qu'il n'y
aurait qu'une seule banlieue mais c'est
un petit peu aberrant parce que neuilly
c'est la banlieue mais chanteloup les
vignes où les mureaux où ils encourent
dans 78 et la banlieue aussi et ça
vraiment rien à voir donc c'est vrai
qu'à une vision complètement bas
monochrome à tout point de vue que ce
soient sociales ou ethniques de
banlieue alors que c'est beaucoup plus
riche que ça en a l'air c'est aussi pour
ça qu'ils retournent d'artistes qui
émerge de banlieue parce que la richesse
la diversité culturelle ou sociale ou
même géographique elle fait qu'on a
peut-être une capacité d'adaptation qui
est plus importante que dans d'autres
zones
[Musique]
on est quasiment des prototypes des
jeunes qui ne savent pas parler en
france alors quand ben voilà on a un
rapport très libertaires au langage mais
on sur utilise le langage ont le tort
il ya énormément la plupart des
expressions elles viennent d'une ville
de banlieue puis et rayonnant banlieue
puis rayonne sur toute la france en
passant par paris entre temps par
exemple typiquement le type de ma série
sénat remet à l'eau à la base la rva
l'os est un mot qui vient de la
communauté gitane ça c'est beaucoup
répandue vers montreuil dans ce coin-là
du 93 parce qu'il y avait une grosse
communauté gitane et là ça fait 5 disant
que ça rayonne partout en ile de france
voire en france et après c'est marrant
ce cas d expression par contre qu'il
reste coincé dans un département
ah pardon dans cette suite on a beaucoup
qui se manie de rami 5 ici pour dire que
c'est quelqu'un de duras est un qui est
cette explosion n'a jamais bougé les
frontières des 78kg un mec qui dit ça
c'est un mec 10,78 que ce soit le par
les banlieusards entre guillemets
l'espèce d'accent qu'on peut avoir et
qu'on peut tenir sur toute une vie ou la
manière d' employer les mots c'est
quelque chose qui est énormément après
imiter bas à l'échelle nationale pour le
langage est aussi cet aspect là où on
doit beaucoup meubler le temps de nos
bus c'est toutes les heures où te pour
aller à paris ça nous met deux heures et
demie on attend le premier train de
parnasse le matin des trucs comme ça
éduquons doit meubler tout ce temps là
et c'est vrai que ça nous amène à
raconter des histoires une vie des
anecdotes souvent un petit peu
incroyable pour meubler cet ennui déjà
et après on passe énormément de temps à
se raconter ses anecdotes et ses des
groupes de jeunes souvent à un stage là
entre 15 et 18 ans donc ça ça raconte
autant la jeunesse que la banlieue mais
mais peut-être particulièrement en
banlieue la parole il faut réussir à
aller la chercher
[Musique]
n'aurait que de la violence en banlieue
ça ces fonds à plein d'égards enfin déjà
on dit qu'il ya de la violence en
banlieue
en fait on a regroupé une quantité de
pauvres absolument invraisemblable au
même endroit et parfois au milieu de no
man's land un quartier comme le
val-fourré je crois que c'est une des
plus grosses cités d'europe ça a quand
même plus de vingt mille habitants
soissons précarité qu'on met ensemble au
milieu de quatre champs mois en fait je
trouve que ça se passe plutôt bien ou du
moins ça pourrait aboutir à des
résultats bien plus dramatique d'avoir
une politique urbaine aussi aussi
débiles et surtout on retrouve on
retrouve aussi dans l'est dans les cités
dans les quartiers à une mentalité de
proximité humaine qui est beaucoup plus
important pas quelque chose de l'ordre
du village mais un petit peu où les gens
quand même ils se connaissent si
quelqu'un disparaît on s'inquiète de sa
disparition il ya de l'entr'aide
notamment pendant le avec la pandémie
due qu'aux vide
il ya eu beaucoup d'auto organisation
associative pour aller livrer des repas
aux personnes les plus âgées ou les
puces les plus démunis pour qu'ils aient
encore de quoi sourire même s'il avait
moins de revenus il ya aussi une culture
de la débrouillardise hyper importante
en banlieue il ya un truc qu'on fait
avec ce qu'on a
on s'adapte à la situation on va se
débrouiller on va aussi se débrouiller
par les autres chacun un petit peu
sceptique compétences et on a laissé
faire de la mécanique le tice et faire
sa loterie c'est faire des lettres de
motiver chacun avec ses micros
compétences rend la vie un petit peu
plus légère à son entourage
la banlieue particulièrement je trouvais
1 voilà un terreau de diversité
d'enrichissement personnel de
rayonnement culturel de devis quale
d'humanité qui qui persistent et qui a
une identité unique motion archi content
d'avoir grandi en banlieue j'aurais
voulu grandir nulle part ailleurs
et voilà